dude that move that move there's been
times where i've been to the verge of
tears it's actually giving me a headache
trying to watch this and like analyze it
this is all i'm seeing
hey guys welcome back to another episode
of stuntman react we're happy to be able
to finally film with guests again and
gee has graciously come in gui is a
legend he's done some incredible things
he's going to give you that professional
insight into one of the most unique and
coolest jobs that you could ever
possibly have so yeah we're gonna hop
into some clips here let's get started
with one of my favorite kung fu movies
of all time
kung fu hustle is directed by one of my
all-time favorite directors i could go
on for hours about how much i love
steven chow i love his versatility
definitely one of my favorite directors
of all time he is a genius
[Music]
so good
so he's in he's on the hong kong harness
which only it's like a belt and it goes
through it's similar to what climbing
harness looks like okay he's picked at
the hips sadly when he jumps they they
time it with him and doesn't lift up his
shirt or anything like that what i
really like about the hong kong harness
is the fact that it allows your
athleticism to be part of the
performance rather than you just going
for the ride yes since which they need
him to do at this moment because he he
has to be in rhythm with them and bounce
and jump at the same time and throw the
kicks and land
and have that weight on top of it
kick them so hard dust comes off of them
they need to wash their clothes some
more wait a second how'd they get that
dust puff
on that face kick right here look at
this did he throw it with his hand no
it's on his foot it just flicks off his
toe also in a little bit later you can
see there's a part where he just slides
his foot through a pile to kick it up
into the air also ghee what do you use
for that dust i mean usually you use
baby powder but there is another kind of
dust that's a little bit thicker that we
use
you just slam his head on the ground oh
nope no that was like you showed himself
that was great that was actually a
really good reaction
wow look he used his arm to save himself
he's like boom just enough just you just
just
dude that enough got launched look at
this guy
roller coaster ride
[Music]
that's so rad such a sick reveal well
this part's cg right that's real this is
real and then he goes
absolutely vfx and then this is just
glued together
[Music]
is that like a real martial art style i
believe it's hungar it's a northern
style so it's very deep stances the the
style tiger that you see in kung fu
films for the most part is of that
origin which also will explain why a lot
of the
martial art movements of this style is
it's always so big and round because
they're actually hitting with their
forearms more than their fists at times
[Music]
dude that move yeah double the jump
split back kicks
he does a really good job of making
impossible moves look possible right
he's very anime inspired yeah that's
what i really liked about kung fu hustle
and resonated with me was his ability to
take ideas from animation and put it
into dude live action 100 he is the best
director who's done anime to live action
style yes um like shaolin soccer dude
right
[Music]
[Applause]
dude doing it nonstop and everybody's
just running out
dude aim for the top hats
[Laughter]
so much style so much like that that
soul that's in it makes it even more fun
to watch he's got the craziness in his
eyes he's got the desperate yeah
he stomps with his foot when he hits at
the same time and he holds it and
everything just shakes because there's
so much force behind it yeah and like
his chest is back you know it's not like
it's
good yeah it's so important
if anybody catches a fly on screen by
the way i'm i'm gonna i'm um
by the end of this episode that that fly
is mine
hey we love hearing from you guys what's
your favorite martial arts movie in fact
what's your favorite martial arts scene
leave a comment down below we love
taking a look we'll break it down on the
show right here
[Music]
there's there's been times on this show
where i've doubled uh turk where i've
been to the verge of tears
because of how how how much it hurts
working nights in new york city during
the fall winter is not fun okay
[Music]
so there's a fall here that i wasn't a
fan of
[Music]
so
it's new york city it's 2 a.m
close to 15 degrees outside and it's
about 10 feet 15 feet they are like he's
you're gonna you're gonna hit and splat
i'm like cool this is going to be great
we're going to put a little neoprene mat
for you and neoprene's like this thick
you know that neoprene was actually
harder than the roof really why because
when it's cold
it stiffens up even more i did that
maybe seven times i might as well should
just been landing on the ground without
it because it's not only just the impact
but then it's the freezing burn that
comes after it
of your palms gang scraping across your
your chest
get smacking and
that wasn't fun
at all here's my thing though
in the edit well you don't see the full
thing right there's more to the chase
than what they actually showed
and they they cut a good chunk of it out
so i'm supposed to land on it on a lower
ledge then jump to the stairs that you
see over there
and then i'm supposed to run and instead
of go down the last flight i'm supposed
to just jump
and just try to make it and that's what
we do but you know you don't see it in
the shot it just looks like i fell from
on top of a ledge so again you do a
whole bunch of work and at times you're
only going to get a third of it shown
you know in the edit
charlie cox is really cool though we
were doing squats to stay warm he does
squats before every scene like before
they start action he he pumps his heart
up he just gets it going every like no
matter it's cold no matter it's hot
everything i'm gonna tell him he should
come on here yeah and then you guys
should do an actor's react you think he
would do that i don't see why not
wait hold on hold on hold on charlie cox
just called me and he said nico
i'm not going to go on your show
until quarter crew gets 4 million
subscribers i'm like you know what
charlie cox we're at
3.91 so we just need 90 000 subscribers
that's right guys help us get charlie
cox in the show right now
hey
did you get it oh you got it oh my god
okay close up get it
whoa you got duked
punches like a pansy
it's
health bar is like down a little bit now
yeah we'll move it slower now
[Music]
so game of thrones has some great sword
fights and has some not great sword
fights
i remember being pretty disappointed
with this fight ceiling
[Laughter]
[Music]
these shots aren't really even showing
any beat in particular like there you go
okay you show the block and then you
show the swing and then
like now draw it and he's going for a
thrust so i feel like they double cut
that so that strike that we see that
overhand it the close-up that follows
afterwards is actually for that strike
yeah i agree 100 that's just that's the
same move right there play it again
[Laughter]
just kidding i'm back in the fight
oh she won she's bested him somehow no
no i like literally now
she keeps him in the back of the knee
like actually what happened like really
what happened it's been moved and then
she kicked him this is all i'm seeing
like
i feel like
she did that move once and they made it
look like she did it twice yeah okay
that's probably what it was and then
somehow he's down i still don't know how
he's down right here it's
right kick
blink
impact them for some reason the most
backwards like far away angle for a kick
also the hound is like the toughest
[ __ ] in westeros he gets bonked
in the chin with her toe and now he's
down
yeah it's actually it's like it's
actually giving me a headache trying to
watch this and like analyze it i'm
trying to find it like it's cut so
roughly and like yeah just none of the
angles flow like they're forcing they're
forcing it really hard yeah like i can't
breathe watching this
yeah this is better
than the
sword fight yeah it's still it's getting
a little oof getting a little oh now
we're jumping it feels like a camera
crew was just told to get a couple
angles of a fight scene so they did and
then there's just no cohesion you think
they were just out there they're like
all right we gotta film all this stuff
you guys just just film this section
just film the fight scene i kind of feel
i don't know man like it was really this
is a big build up and i think it was
just a case of like you know both the
actors wanted to do the scene themselves
some people just don't quite have it yet
for sword fighting you know when they do
the matrix you know keanu reeves and
lawrence fishburne they all have to
train for like months and months and
months and i feel like this is like a
couple weeks and it's also tv it's also
tv there's been good fights on this show
the bow the bastards that was very well
done it's an amazing fight scene and the
trial by combat yeah oh that's not a
good fight leong is dope the same dude
would choreographed and doubled uh for
that fight scene he is in mission
impossible fallout he fought henry
cavill and
yeah so they've captured stuff way
better than that let's just say they
didn't have a lot of time on set you
know i would i would ascertain they
maybe had a day or two to shoot this
entire scene gee yes what would you do
to make the scene better i would get the
shots that you need with your actors
your big points and then i would use the
wides that they have where they're using
the stunt performers and let that be the
the brandishing of the fight
choreography and then cut in for the
more visceral intimate scenes that come
on later on but then it's up to the
editor to make that come to fruition and
i don't think it happened here and i get
what they're trying to do because these
are two very important characters to the
story and they want to show them both
being powerful but they're trying to get
to the point of brienne being able to
win her being a better fighter they
could have played more to that and
showed how she has to be smarter she has
to be more strategic than just also
being a brawler or if they want her to
just be a brawler then they should just
clash swords somehow they both get
disarmed and get right to the point of
the nitty-gritty where they're punching
and headbutting one another and then
show who has the best who who has the
most heart in that aspect what i would
do is i would make it almost just like a
uh like a samurai showdown where it's
like two dudes stare at each other talk
look like they shot their hands up in
the swords the blades shining in the
sunlight the sweat dripping down the
chin and they yell they write each other
bling bling bling and they break apart
again it's just like two or three hits
and i wouldn't worry about the
choreography at all because clearly the
choreography isn't that good it would
just be entirely about the emotion
setting up a fight and doing a fight on
tel for television and doing it for film
or you you have different time with your
actors in comparison they also have to
they're probably trying to shoot
multiple things at the same time because
it's shot in so many different places
and i wonder if this was a splinter unit
trying to get this fight together so i
give them some sort of leeway but they
got way too much money and budget for
game of thrones to look like this
i saw someone die late last night
have you been taking your medication
you don't get it she's here
she followed me here you're not in your
right state of mind
[Music]
[Music]
key catch and fly catch and fly it's
orbiting you wait for it there it is
oh you did it you did it it's right
there
[Music]
oh my gosh gee thank you so much for
joining us guys follow ghee on instagram
if you have not he has some awesome
stuff ask him some questions maybe he'll
respond
did you get it
oh my god oh sh
how many are there how many are there